Narrator: TONIGHT,
MUSIC INDUSTRY VETERAN
AND ACCOMPLISHED INVESTOR
TROY CARTER JOINS THE TANK.
THERE'S ANOTHER KID
IN A GARAGE
THAT WANTS TO EAT YOUR LUNCH
RIGHT NOW.
IN THE TANK,
ENTREPRENEURS SEEK AN INVESTMENT
TO START, GROW,
OR SAVE THEIR BUSINESSES.
IF THE SHARKS HEAR
A GREAT IDEA...
WHOA.
[ LAUGHTER ]
...THEY'LL INVEST
THEIR OWN MONEY
AND FIGHT EACH OTHER FOR A DEAL.
I'M WILLING
TO WRITE A CHECK.
YOU DON'T JUST WANT MONEY.
YOU WANT A PARTNER.
I LOVE A GUY
THAT'S WILLING TO GIVE ADVICE,
BUT HE WON'T WRITE A CHECK.
Narrator:
BUT THE ENTREPRENEURS MUST GET
THE FULL AMOUNT
THEY'RE ASKING FOR
OR THEY'LL WALK AWAY
WITH NOTHING.
HOW MUCH HAVE YOU SOLD?
$900,000
IN THE LAST 12 MONTHS.
YOU'RE RIGHT ON TREND.
WHERE ARE YOU CURRENTLY
SELLING THESE?
NOWHERE.
I KNEW THAT WE TOOK A RISK
IN BEING HERE EARLY.
-HUGE MISTAKE.
-YOU'RE DEAD TO ME.
Narrator:
WHO ARE THE SHARKS?
THEY'RE SELF-MADE
BUSINESS EXPERTS WORTH BILLIONS.
KEVIN O'LEARY IS
A SHREWD VENTURE CAPITALIST
WHO MADE HIS FORTUNE
SELLING A CHILDREN'S
EDUCATIONAL COMPANY
FOR OVER $4 BILLION.
DAYMOND JOHN DOMINATED
THE FASHION WORLD WITH FUBU.
NOW HE'S THE BRANDING EXPERT
BEHIND MULTIPLE GLOBAL BRANDS,
GENERATING BILLIONS IN SALES.
LORI GREINER, THE QUEEN OF QVC,
HOLDS OVER 100 PATENTS
AND HAS LAUNCHED
MORE THAN 400 PRODUCTS,
GROSSING OVER A HALF A BILLION
DOLLARS IN SALES.
MARK CUBAN,
ESTEEMED BILLIONAIRE TECH MOGUL
AND THE OUTSPOKEN OWNER
OF THE DALLAS MAVERICKS.
AND TROY CARTER.
HE CLIMBED HIS WAY UP
THE MUSIC INDUSTRY LADDER
FROM THE TOUGH NEIGHBORHOODS
OF PHILADELPHIA
TO BECOME A POWERHOUSE
TALENT MANAGER
WITH HIS MEDIA COMPANY
ATOM FACTORY.
HIS ANGEL AND TECH FUNDS
HAVE 70-PLUS INVESTMENTS
IN HIGH-PROFILE COMPANIES LIKE
POP CHIPS, UBER, AND SPOTIFY.
FIRST INTO THE TANK
IS A BUSINESS
THAT REGULARLY BRINGS A HAPPY
SURPRISE TO YOUR MAILBOX.
♪♪
HELLO, SHARKS.
IT'S A PLEASURE
TO MAKE YOUR ACQUAINTANCE.
MY NAME'S BRYAN DELUCA.
AND I'M MATT McLARD.
WE'RE FROM THE GREAT CITY
OF DALLAS, TEXAS,
AND WE'RE SEEKING $250,000
IN EXCHANGE FOR 10% EQUITY
IN OUR COMPANY FOOT CARDIGAN.
WHAT IS FOOT CARDIGAN?
[ GREINER LAUGHS ]
FOOT CARDIGAN
IS THE RADDEST, BADDEST
SOCK-SUBSCRIPTION COMPANY
IN ALL THE LAND.
WE DESIGN AWESOME SOCKS
FOR MEN, WOMEN, AND KIDS
AND DELIVER THEM
ALL OVER THE WORLD EVERY MONTH.
WE TAKE THE OTHERWISE
SNOOZE OF AN ERRAND
OF GOING TO THE STORE
TO BUY SOCKS
AND TURN IT INTO SOMETHING
NOT ONLY SUPER FUN,
BUT SUPER CONVENIENT,
AS WELL.
OUR SOCK FAIRY
CAREFULLY SELECTS
A RANDOM PAIR OF SOCKS
TO MAGICALLY APPEAR
IN OUR CUSTOMERS' MAILBOXES
EVERY MONTH.
SO THEY NEVER KNOW
WHAT THEY'RE GONNA GET.
BASICALLY, WE'RE SPREADING CHEER
ALL OVER THE PLANET
ONE PAIR OF SOCKS
AT A TIME.
SO, SHARKS, I HOPE YOU'RE READY
TO STEP UP YOUR SOCK GAME.
WHICH IS A CRAZY
COINCIDENCE
BECAUSE I HAVE MAILBOXES
RIGHT HERE
WITH EACH OF YOUR NAMES
ON THEM.
LET'S SEE WHAT THE SOCK FAIRY
BROUGHT YOU.
♪♪
-THIS IS HOW THEY COME?
-YES.
-THANK YOU.
-YOU'RE WELCOME.
APPRECIATE IT.
AWW. HEARTS.
SO, HOW LONG HAVE YOU
BEEN DOING THIS BUSINESS?
WE JUST PASSED
THREE YEARS IN JUNE.
CONGRATS.
AND WHAT HAVE
YOUR SALES BEEN?
OVERALL SALES,
THE DURATION OF THE COMPANY --
$1.36 MILLION.
HOW MANY SUBSCRIBERS?
CURRENTLY, WE HAVE
ABOUT 6,000 SUBSCRIBERS.
-6,000?
-MM-HMM.
AND IF I GO TO YOUR SITE
AND SAY I WANT TO BE
PART OF THIS WONDERFUL
EXPERIENCE OF A SOCK A MONTH...
MM-HMM.
...HOW MUCH
DOES IT COST ME?
$9 A MONTH.
-THAT'S NOT BAD.
-$2 SHIPPING,
AND ACTUALLY $3 SHIPPING
ANYWHERE IN THE WORLD.
SO WE DO INTERNATIONAL,
AS WELL.
HOW LONG
DO I HAVE TO SIGN UP FOR?
YOU BASICALLY HAVE
TWO DIFFERENT OPTIONS.
YOU CAN DO
A MONTH-TO-MONTH SUBSCRIPTION.
THE OTHER OPTIONS
ARE 3, 6, 9, AND 12 MONTHS.
THEY WORK GREAT
FOR GIFTS.
YOU KNOW, AND THAT'S
JUST A PREPAID SUBSCRIPTION
FOR EACH OF THOSE AMOUNTS.
I HAVE A QUESTION.
SO, ONE OF YOUR SOCKS
IS LOWER THAN THE OTHER.
IS THAT TO SHOW US THAT YOU HAVE
KIDS' SIZE AND ADULT SIZE?
NO, IT JUST FELL DOWN
ON MY ANKLE, ON MY CALF.
SO I'M GONNA DO THIS.
FIXED.
WALK US THROUGH YOUR
CUSTOMER-ACQUISITION COST,
YOUR COST OF GOODS,
LIFETIME VALUE, ATTRITION RATE.
-GIVE IT TO US.
-AND REMEMBER ALL THAT.
SO, OUR COST PER SOCK
IS $1.32 A PAIR.
THAT'S LANDED OR DELIVERED
TO THE CUSTOMER?
THAT'S LANDED.
SO THAT YOU AGGREGATE --
AND YOU'RE MAKING THEM
OVERSEAS?
Deluca: YEAH, WE MAKE THEM
CURRENTLY IN TURKEY...
SO YOU SHIP THEM IN.
...CHINA, OCCASIONALLY THE U.S.,
WHEN IT MAKES SENSE.
BUT THE GREAT THING
ABOUT OUR MODEL
IS THAT YOU GET A RANDOM PAIR
EVERY MONTH.
RIGHT.
SO WE DON'T REALLY HAVE
MUCH INVENTORY ISSUES
'CAUSE WE CAN ALWAYS PUSH
THROUGH IT.
SO RIGHT NOW IS, WHAT, $60,000
MONTH-OVER-MONTH REVENUE?
IT'S A LITTLE TRICKY
BECAUSE WE'RE SO SEASONAL.
SO, YOU KNOW, FOR HOLIDAYS,
LIKE IN JANUARY AND FEBRUARY --
I THINK WHEN VALENTINE'S
WAS OVER,
WE ENDED UP HAVING
ABOUT 12,000 SUBSCRIBERS
AT THAT ONE GIVEN TIME.
AND THEN DROP OFF.
WE HAVE THE EBB AND FLOW
LIKE A CLASSIC RETAILER.
WHO IS YOUR BIGGEST
CUSTOMER?
DEFINITELY MEN.
I MEAN, YOU'RE RIGHT ON TREND,
OBVIOUSLY, RIGHT?
MEN ARE REALLY
INTO THESE CRAZY SOCKS.
EVEN MARK IS WEARING THEM,
RIGHT?
I'VE GOT LIKE
500 DIFFERENT ONES, YEAH.
WHAT HAS BEEN YOUR SALE
IN THE LAST 12 MONTHS?
ABOUT $900,000
IN THE LAST 12 MONTHS.
-$900,000?
-GOOD FOR YOU.
-THAT'S A LOT OF SOCKS.
-THAT IS A LOT OF SOCKS.
ARE YOU GUYS TAKING
A SALARY?
SO, WE'RE GONNA DO $1.5 MILLION
THIS YEAR.
WHAT ARE YOUR BACKGROUNDS?
'CAUSE IT SOUNDS LIKE
THE WAY YOU'RE TALKING,
YOU HAVE A TECH BACKGROUND
OR AN S.E.O. BACKGROUND.
YEAH, SO, MY BACKGROUND'S
IN CONVERSION OPTIMIZATION.
OKAY.
I WORKED AT A MARKETING AGENCY
IN DALLAS,
AND JUST LOVED
THE PSYCHOLOGY OF,
WHAT ARE PEOPLE DOING
ON THE WEBSITE?
GETTING THEM TO BUY,
AND WHAT PUSHES THEM TO BUY.
SO, WE HAVE ALMOST
A 7% CONVERSION RATE
ON FOOT CARDIGAN
RIGHT NOW.
THEN WHY AREN'T
YOUR NUMBERS HIGHER?
IF YOU HAVE THAT BIG
A CONVERSION RATE
AND YOU HAVE THOSE MARGINS,
YOU SHOULD BE JUST PLOWING IN.
SO, WE JUST CAME FULL-TIME.
FOR THE FIRST 2 1/2 YEARS,
WE DID THIS ALL ON THE SIDE
BETWEEN --
THERE'S FOUR CO-FOUNDERS.
WE HAVE EIGHT KIDS.
WE WERE WORKING FULL-TIME JOBS,
GETTING THIS THING GOING.
WHY ARE YOU NOT MAKING
DOMESTICALLY?
'CAUSE YOU CAN TURN THIS
FAIRLY QUICKLY DOMESTICALLY.
IT'LL SAVE YOU
FROM AN INVENTORY POSITION.
NUMBER ONE,
IT WAS PRICE.
YOU KNOW, BECAUSE I INVESTED
IN A COMPANY CALLED BAMBAS.
-RIGHT.
AND THESE GUYS ARE, LIKE,
ON FIRE.
AND THEIR DOMESTIC CHALLENGE
IS THAT THEY CAN'T FIND
A CERTAIN MACHINE
THAT IS SEAMLESS IN THE SOCK.
BUT THIS SOCK IS READILY
AVAILABLE TO THE MARKET.
IT'S A QUALITY SOCK.
I LIKE THIS.
-THANK YOU.
-SO ARE YOU OPEN TO DOMESTIC?
-ABSOLUTELY.
-OF COURSE.
WHO ARE YOUR COMPETITORS
OUT THERE RIGHT NOW?
WELL, WE HAVE
A LOT OF COMPETITORS.
BECAUSE THE MARGINS
ARE SO HIGH.
EVERYBODY WANTS SOCKS --
WANTS TO SELL SOCKS.
SURE, BUT I THINK
THAT'S A REALLY GOOD POINT.
SO RIGHT NOW WE'RE ONE OF THE
FEW SOCK-SUBSCRIPTION COMPANIES
THAT MANUFACTURE
AND MAKE OUR OWN.
SO I THINK WE'RE DOING
QUITE A BIT BETTER
THAN MOST OF OUR COMPETITION.
MEANING THEY'RE GOING
TO THIRD PARTIES
AND WHOLESALING THEM
FROM THEM,
AND SO WE KNOW OUR MARGINS
ARE MUCH BETTER.
SO, NOW, WHAT IF I --
I GET A PAIR OF SOCKS.
FIRST MONTH,
I DON'T LIKE IT.
THE SECOND MONTH,
I DON'T LIKE, SAY, THE DESIGN.
IS THERE AN OPTION FOR ME
TO SAY, "YOU KNOW WHAT, GUYS,
I WANT TO START
PICKING MY SOCK"?
NOT RIGHT NOW. NO.
I DON'T THINK
YOU EVER WANT TO GET THERE.
BECAUSE IT'S TOO HARD FOR YOU
TO HAVE THAT?
RIGHT.
IF YOU HAVE TO MAINTAIN
INVENTORY SKEWS
BASED ON DEMAND
AND SELECTION,
THIS WHOLE MODEL
GOES OUT THE WINDOW.
WE GET FEEDBACK ALL THE TIME
FROM PEOPLE SAYING,
"I CANNOT WAIT
UNTIL I OPEN MY MAILBOX
AND THOSE FOOT CARDIGAN
SOCKS ARE THERE."
JUST OUT OF INTEREST,
IF I GIVE YOU $250,000 FOR 10%,
HOW DO I EVER GET
MY MONEY BACK?
WE THINK, HONESTLY,
WITH THIS VALUATION
AND THE $250,000,
WE BELIEVE THAT YOU COULD
GET IT BACK IN THREE YEARS.
WHY DO YOU THINK
THAT IT'LL TAKE THREE YEARS
TO GET US BACK $250,000?
THAT'S QUITE SOME TIME.
I DON'T KNOW TIME FRAMES
IN TERMS OF GETTING MONEY BACK.
I THINK THAT WE'RE GONNA MAKE
SURE WE'RE GONNA GET $3 MILLION.
O'Leary:
IF YOU'RE WILLING TO GIVE
DISTRIBUTIONS TO SHAREHOLDERS,
YOU KNOW, WE HAVE MANY OPTIONS
OF WHERE WE DEPLOY OUR CAPITAL.
WE'RE LOOKING FOR THE HIGHEST
RETURN, LOWEST RISK.
YOU KNOW,
I WOULD SAY THIS --
WE BOOTSTRAPPED
THIS COMPANY.
WE PUT $6,000 OF OUR OWN CASH
INTO IT. THAT'S IT.
-IN THREE YEARS.
-GOOD FOR YOU GUYS.
SO WE'RE GONNA CONTINUE TO GROW
THAT SUBSCRIPTION MODEL
WITH JUST FINDING
NEW CUSTOMERS.
WE FOUND, YOU KNOW,
EARLY ON,
PEOPLE DIDN'T EVEN KNOW
SOCK SUBSCRIPTIONS WAS A THING,
SO WE'VE GOT TO GET
IN FRONT OF MORE PEOPLE.
I THINK THEY'RE CUTE,
BUT IT'S A VERY CROWDED MARKET.
TO ME, YOU'RE NOT DOING
SOMETHING DIFFERENT.
JUST DOING IT
IN A DIFFERENT WAY.
SURE.
I'M NOT SURE HOW I WOULD MAKE
BACK MY $250,000 VERY QUICKLY.
I'M OUT.
-OKAY.
-THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
YEAH, THANKS, LORI.
SO, YOU GUYS, YOU KNOW,
THIS NEVER HAPPENS,
WHERE I ACTUALLY GIVE AN OFFER
TO TWO GUYS IN THEIR UNDERWEAR.
[ LAUGHS ]
I WILL GIVE YOU $250,000
FOR 22.5%.
AND IT HAS TO BE CONTINGENT
THAT MY BAMBAS PARTNERS
WANT TO WORK
WITH THE DEAL.
I HAVE TO BE GOOD PARTNERS
TO THEM.
-AWESOME.
-OKAY.
I'LL GIVE YOU $250,000 FOR 15%
WITH SOME SCHEDULE OF RETURNS
'CAUSE I DON'T REALLY SEE
A SOCK-SUBSCRIPTION BUSINESS
DOING AN I.P.O.
ON THE NEW YORK STOCK EXCHANGE.
SO, WHAT SCHEDULE?
YEAH, WHAT DOES THAT
LOOK LIKE?
DO QUARTERLY DISTRIBUTIONS TO
EVERYBODY, INCLUDING YOURSELVES.
IN OTHER WORDS,
YOU START TO DISTRIBUTE MONEY.
I TAKE IT OUT THE SAME TIME
YOU GUYS DO.
IN THE LONG RUN, THAT'S WHY
YOU INVEST IN A BUSINESS.
RIGHT. MAKES SENSE.
NO, THANKS FOR THAT OFFER.
THAT'S AWESOME.
Carter: IF YOU'RE GONNA VALUE
THIS AS A TECH COMPANY
AND EVENTUALLY RAISE
VENTURE CAPITAL,
IT'S GONNA BE HARD
TO JUSTIFY TO INVESTORS
THAT YOU'RE GIVEN DISTRIBUTIONS
TO A PREVIOUS TIER OF INVESTORS.
AT MY COMPANY ATOM FACTORY,
WE PROBABLY INVESTED IN OVER
ABOUT 65 TECHNOLOGY COMPANIES,
ALSO CONSUMER PACKAGED GOODS,
IN ADDITION TO STANCE SOCKS,
WHICH, YOU KNOW,
IS A ROCKET SHIP RIGHT NOW.
WHAT I LIKE ABOUT YOU GUYS
IS THE FACT THAT YOU'RE GOING
AFTER THIS
SUBSCRIPTION BUSINESS,
WHICH I THINK THERE'S
A HUGE MARKET THERE.
SO WHAT I'M GONNA OFFER
IS 250K FOR 15%.
NO DISTRIBUTIONS.
AND I THINK ONE OF THE THINGS
YOUR BRAND IS GONNA NEED
IS A NARRATIVE.
IN ORDER TO BE ABLE TO MAKE
YOUR BRAND DEFENSIBLE,
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE TO CREATE
SOME SORT OF CONNECTION
WITH THE CONSUMER
OUTSIDE OF THE SOCK.
AND THAT'S A SPACE I THINK
I'M ABLE TO HELP YOU GUYS IN.
AND THEN THERE'S ONE --
MARK.
THEN THERE'S MARK.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT HE'S DOING.
ONE GUY LEFT.
THE DALLAS GUY.
Narrator: ONE SHARK IS OUT.
BRYAN AND MATT HAVE THREE OFFERS
ON THE TABLE
FOR THEIR SOCK-SUBSCRIPTION
COMPANY, FOOT CARDIGAN.
BUT THEY HAVE YET TO HEAR
FROM MARK CUBAN.
AND THEN THERE'S ONE --
MARK.
AND THEN THERE'S MARK.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT HE'S DOING.
-ONE GUY LEFT.
-THE DALLAS GUY.
SEE, THESE GUYS --
OTHER THAN TROY --
THEY'RE, "WHAT CAN YOU
GIVE ME BACK IMMEDIATELY?"
I'M MORE INTERESTED IN,
HOW BIG CAN WE GET?
RIGHT. AND I THINK, AGAIN,
NOW THAT WE'RE FULL-TIME,
WE FINALLY HAVE TIME
TO SCALE THIS THING.
AND IF WE DID WHAT WE DID
FOR THE LAST THREE YEARS
PART-TIME,
WE ARE PLACING MASSIVE BETS
ON OURSELVES
AND OUR FAMILIES'
LIVELIHOODS
THAT WE'RE GONNA GROW
THIS THING, SO...
ALL RIGHT,
WELL, I HAVE AN INTEREST.
I'LL DO A STRAIGHT-UP
250K FOR 20%.
WE'VE GOT FACILITIES
IN DALLAS.
WE CAN TAKE OVER
YOUR ACCOUNTING.
WE CAN TAKE BACK OFFICE.
YOU CAN WORK
WITH ALL OUR TECH GUYS.
I LIKE TROY'S IDEA
OF NARRATIVE.
I THINK HE BRINGS
A UNIQUE SKILL SET THERE.
I THINK YOUR STRENGTH IS,
YOU KNOW,
THE TECHNICAL SIDE,
THE CONVERSION SIDE.
I THINK WE --
YOU KNOW, WE CAN AMP IT UP.
WE CAN DO THINGS
WITH THE MAVS.
THERE'S ALL KINDS
OF PROMOTIONAL OPS.
SO YOUR OFFER'S
$250,000, 20% --
50/50 TO TROY,
IF HE WANTS THAT DEAL.
YEAH, TROY, IF YOU WANT TO COME
IN WITH ME, WE'LL SPLIT IT.
OKAY, MARK,
I'LL DO THAT DEAL.
SO, WITH YOU GUYS SPLITTING,
IT WOULD BE 20%...
-TOTAL.
250K FOR 20% TOTAL.
TROY AND I WILL SPLIT IT
DOWN THE MIDDLE.
SO EXPENSIVE.
DUDES, LET'S DO THIS!
-DEAL.
-DONE.
-WHOO!
-YEAH, BOY!
-LET'S DO THIS.
-ABSOLUTELY.
-IT'LL BE FUN.
-THANKS, GUYS.
-TAKE CARE.
-THANK YOU SO MUCH.
OH, MY GOSH!
HE'S DOING A HAPPY DANCE.
BOOM!
HOLY COW!
YOU THINK THEY CAN GET
A $10 MILLION VALUATION,
RIGHT, LIKE --
-OH, EASY RIGHT NOW, YEAH.
-RIGHT TODAY.
OUR FAMILIES HAVE MADE
A TON OF SACRIFICES,
AND FOR OTHER PEOPLE,
LIKE MARK AND TROY,
TO SEE THE POTENTIAL
IN WHAT FOOT CARDIGAN HAS
AND WHERE IT CAN GO,
UM, I MEAN, I CAN'T --
I CAN'T EVEN PUT IT
INTO WORDS.
♪♪
YOU KNOW, I LOVE LOVE.
AND I'VE OFFERED TO MARRY
MANY COUPLES IN THE TANK.
DO YOU WANT ME
TO MARRY YOU NOW?
CAN YOU MARRY US?
OF COURSE I CAN.
I'M MR. WONDERFUL.
I'M ACTUALLY NOW LICENSED
TO MARRY PEOPLE.
SO IF YOU'D LIKE TO GET THAT
OVER WITH RIGHT NOW,
I CAN DO IT.
I FINALLY GET TO DO IT.
SOME OF MY CLOSEST FRIENDS
ARE GETTING MARRIED
RIGHT HERE ON NANTUCKET,
AND THEY'VE ASKED ME
TO OFFICIATE THE CEREMONY.
BUT THAT'S NOT ALL.
I LIKE TO MIX A LITTLE BUSINESS
AND PLEASURE TOGETHER SOMETIMES.
SO I'VE ASKED
SOME OF MY BEST COMPANIES --
BOTTLE BREACHER, HONEYFUND,
AND WICKED GOOD CUPCAKES --
TO COME TO THE WEDDING
AND GIVE THEIR PRODUCTS
AND SERVICES
TO THE GROOM AND BRIDE.
SO, SHOW ME WHAT YOU BROUGHT.
WE BROUGHT A HONEYMOON REGISTRY
FOR MATT AND ERICA.
WE BROUGHT THE 20-MILLIMETER
BOTTLE BREACHER
FOR EVERY GUY
AT THE WEDDING.
WE'VE DECIDED
TO CUSTOMIZE CUPCAKE JARS
FOR THE BRIDE AND GROOM.
O'Leary: ALL THREE OF THESE
COMPANIES ARE GOING TO BECOME
PART OF WHAT I'M CALLING
MY SOMETHING WONDERFUL PLATFORM.
OUR PLAN IS TO MAKE A HUGE DENT
IN THE WEDDING INDUSTRY.
LET'S GET CHANGED.
WE'VE GOT A WEDDING TO GO TO.
I PRONOUNCE YOU
MAN AND WIFE.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
YOU MAY KISS THE BRIDE.
YOU KNOW WHAT I LOVE
ABOUT LOVE AND WEDDINGS?
IT'S THE ONE TIME IN YOUR LIFE
WHERE YOU'RE COMPLETELY
IRRATIONAL ABOUT PRICE.
Sara: KEVIN'S ATTENTION
TO OUR BUSINESS
HAS BEEN ABSOLUTELY
LIFE-CHANGING.
IN THE EIGHT MONTHS
SINCE AIRING,
WE'VE ALREADY DONE
$738,000 IN REVENUE.
Eli: WHEN WE WERE PITCHING
ON "SHARK TANK,"
WE HAD $640,000 IN SALES.
IT'S ONLY BEEN SEVEN MONTHS,
AND WE'VE ALREADY DONE
$4.2 MILLION.
Tracey: SINCE PARTNERING
WITH KEVIN TWO YEARS AGO,
OUR SALES HAVE NOW CLIMBED
TO $5.5 MILLION.
IT IS ABSOLUTELY GREAT.
AS A SHARK, WHEN I INVEST,
I'M ALWAYS TRYING
TO FIT COMPANIES TOGETHER.
HOW CAN I MAKE THEM STRONGER?
HOW CAN WE COOPERATE
IN MARKETING TO GROW SALES?
THIS IS THE POWER
OF "SHARK TANK."
I INVESTED
IN THESE THREE COMPANIES.
NOW WE'RE BUILDING OUR FUTURE
ON THE SOMETHING WONDERFUL
PLATFORM.
WE'RE GONNA GROW THIS
TO THE HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS.
Narrator:
NEXT UP IS A MODERN SOLUTION TO
ALLEVIATE THE HASSLE OF PARKING.
♪♪
HELLO, SHARKS.
MY NAME'S WAYNE JOHNSON,
AND I'M AN AWARD-WINNING
WEB DESIGNER
FROM WASHINGTON, D.C.,
SEEKING $300,000 FOR 20% EQUITY
IN MY COMPANY ValPark MOBILE.
ValPark MOBILE IS AN APP
THAT ALLOWS CUSTOMERS
TO PAY FOR VALET
AND GARAGE PARKING
SUPER EASY, FAST, AND SECURE
ALL FROM THEIR SMARTPHONE.
HOW OFTEN HAVE YOU GONE
TO VALET AND REALIZED
YOU DON'T HAVE ANY CASH.
AND THEN WHAT?
YOU DRIVE AROUND IN CIRCLES
LOOKING FOR A PARKING SPACE
YOU MAY NEVER FIND?
OR EVEN WORSE, YOU GO TO AN ATM.
WHERE'S THE CONVENIENCE IN THAT?
ENTER ValPark MOBILE.
ValPark MOBILE HELPS YOU
FIND AND PAY FOR VALET
AT LOCATIONS
SUCH AS RESTAURANTS, HOTELS,
NIGHT CLUBS,
AND EVEN SPORTING ARENAS, MARK.
READY TO LEAVE?
USE OUR APP
TO THEN REQUEST YOUR CAR
AND THEN HAVE IT WAITING
OUTSIDE FOR YOU.
WITH YOUR HELP,
WE CAN MAKE THIS $40 BILLION
ANTIQUATED PARKING INDUSTRY
ValPark MOBILE STANDARD.
LET'S BRING THE CONVENIENCE
BACK TO VALET.
ANY QUESTIONS, SHARKS?
O'Leary:
I HAVE A QUESTION.
LET'S SAY I HAVE
A RESTAURANT,
AND I HAVE A VERY BUOYANT
VALET BUSINESS.
I'M PARKING
250 CARS A NIGHT.
TELL ME HOW YOU ADD VALUE
TO MY SITUATION.
YOU COME TO ME AS AN OWNER
AND SAY...
SKIMMING AMONG VALET PROVIDERS,
IT'S KIND OF ACCEPTED LOSS,
UP TO 30%, IN FACT,
'CAUSE IT'S CASH.
ValPark MOBILE ELIMINATES
A GOOD PORTION OF THAT
BY ALLOWING NOT ONLY
MOBILE TRANSACTIONS,
BUT CREDIT-CARD TRANSACTIONS.
Greiner: I'M NOT SURE I FULLY
UNDERSTAND HOW THIS WORKS.
CAN YOU SHOW US?
YES, CAN YOU EXPLAIN TO US?
SO, YOU WOULD DOWNLOAD
OUR APP.
YOU MAKE A PROFILE --
MARK HAS MADE A PROFILE HERE --
WITH YOUR NAME,
YOUR E-MAIL ADDRESS,
AND YOUR CREDIT-CARD NUMBER.
WHEN YOU CREATE A PROFILE,
YOU ACTUALLY CREATE A SECURE PIN
THAT IS ASSOCIATED
WITH YOUR PROFILE.
SO YOU NEVER TAKE YOUR PHONE
OUT OF YOUR POCKET
WHEN YOU'RE PARKING WITH US.
ALL THE ATTENDANT ASKS FOR
IS YOUR NAME.
-AND YOUR PIN.
-YOU SAY YOUR NAME.
YOU PUT YOUR PIN IN.
YOU'RE CHARGED.
-THAT'S IT. YOU'RE DONE.
-RIGHT.
SO, RIGHT NOW, YOU KNOW,
YOU'RE CLOSING UP YOUR TAB,
YOU REQUEST YOUR VEHICLE.
ALL ATTENDANTS AT THAT LOCATION
WITH THE DEVICE GETS AN ALERT.
I THEN GET AN ALERT
SAYING MY VEHICLE
WILL BE OUTSIDE
IN THREE TO FIVE MINUTES.
WHEN IT'S OUTSIDE,
I THEN GET A SECONDARY ALERT,
AND MY VEHICLE'S OUTSIDE
AND READY TO GO.
HOW MANY LOCATIONS
ARE YOU IN RIGHT NOW?
CURRENTLY,
WE'RE AT OVER 115.
-GOOD FOR YOU.
-IN WHICH MARKETS?
WE'RE IN WASHINGTON, D.C.,
MARYLAND, AND VIRGINIA.
-GOOD FOR YOU.
-AND YOU CREATED THIS YOURSELF?
I DESIGNED THIS MYSELF.
I WIRE-FRAMED THIS, CONCEPTED
THIS, I DID ALL THE ASSETS.
MY BUSINESS PARTNER OWNS
THE LARGEST VALET COMPANY
ON THE EAST COAST.
AND WHAT'S YOUR ARRANGEMENT
WITH YOUR BUSINESS PARTNER?
HE OWNS
46% OF THE BUSINESS.
MM-HMM.
Johnson: HE WAS LOOKING
FOR A SOLUTION LIKE THIS
BECAUSE THEY CAN'T TAKE
CREDIT CARDS.
HOW MANY PEOPLE CARRY AROUND
MORE THAN $25 AT ONCE
IN THEIR POCKET ANYMORE?
NO, YOU'RE SOLVING A PROBLEM.
THERE'S NO QUESTION.
THE QUESTION IS,
HOW BIG CAN YOU GET?
HE'S SAYING
HOW SCALABLE IS IT?
YEAH, BECAUSE THERE'S
ONE OF THOSE IN EVERY MARKET --
THE GUY WHO DOMINATES
VALET PARKING.
YOU NEED TO GET TO YOUR PARTNER
IN EVERY CITY.
IF I WENT AND LOOKED
AT SAN FRANCISCO,
I'D FIND ONE GUY HAS 60%
OF ALL THE VALET COMPANIES
AND THE OTHERS
ARE ALL SPLIT UP.
YOU NEED THE 60% GUY
IN EVERY MARKET.
-HOW ARE YOU GONNA DO IT?
-THAT'S THE PLAN.
LAST YEAR, WE STARTED
WITH BETA IN 33 LOCATIONS.
NOW WE'RE AT OVER 115.
SO WHAT'S YOUR SALES?
LAST YEAR, WE DID $270,000.
HOW MANY YEARS DID YOU SAY
YOU'VE BEEN DOING IT?
WE STARTED IT LAST YEAR.
WE WENT LIVE LAST YEAR.
AND WHAT PERCENTAGE
DO YOU TAKE?
SO, FIRST YEAR --
THIS IS HOW WE MAKE OUR MONEY.
WE ADDED AN 8.5% CONVENIENCE FEE
TO WHATEVER THE PRINCIPAL WAS.
8.5% TO THE CONSUMER?
THAT'S PASSED DOWN
TO THE CONSUMER.
AND THIS IS WHY VENDORS
LOVE US --
WE DON'T TAKE THEIR PRINCIPAL.
NOW, ARE YOU SAYING
YOU DID $270,000 GROSS,
AND THEN TO YOU,
BASICALLY,
YOU WOULD HAVE DONE
APPROXIMATELY $25,000?
$28,000.
THIS YEAR,
OUR NEW BUSINESS MODEL --
WE'VE MOVED
TO $15% CONVENIENCE FEE.
WE SPLIT THE CREDIT-CARD FEE
DOWN THE MIDDLE
WITH THE PROVIDER.
AND THEN WE ALSO HAVE
A $49-PER-MONTH FEE
FOR EACH LOCATION
AS A VENDOR.
THIS IS A VERY, VERY OLD MARKET
IN AN INDUSTRY
THAT THEY HAVE NOT EVER SEEN
AN URGE OR NEED TO IMPROVE UPON.
ONE OF THE PROBLEMS
IN TECH RIGHT NOW
IS IT'S A COPYCAT MARKET.
SO THE MOMENT
YOU GET SOME HEAT,
THIS IS GONNA SCALE VERY QUICKLY
AROUND THE WORLD.
HOW DO YOU PREVENT YOURSELF
FROM ONLY BEING STUCK
IN THAT TRI-STATE AREA?
HOW DO YOU GET TO SCALE
MORE QUICKLY?
I NEED AN AMBASSADOR
IN EACH CITY.
HAVE YOU TRIED
TO RAISE MONEY?
SO, ALL THIS WAS DONE BY MYSELF
OUT OF MY OWN MONEY SO FAR.
-HOW MUCH?
-$100,000 MYSELF.
-DAMN. THAT'S A LOT OF MONEY.
-YOU'RE IN.
YEAH, I'M IN IT TILL THE END.
SO...
I SEE IT WORK, RIGHT?
I MEAN, IT DOES
WHAT IT'S SUPPOSED TO DO.
THE PROBLEM, LIKE,
WITH A LOT OF APPS
IS HOW MUCH MONEY
CAN YOU ACTUALLY MAKE?
49 BUCKS PER LOCATION,
RIGHT?
GET 1,000 LOCATIONS,
10 TIMES THE SIZE.
TO YOU, AS A ONE-MAN OPERATOR,
THAT'S MONEY IN THE BANK, RIGHT?
YOU'RE SMILING ALL THE WAY.
BUT NOW,
OUT OF 115 LOCATIONS,
YOU MADE $28,000,
AND EVEN IF YOU DOUBLE THAT,
YOU'VE MADE $56,000.
-YEAH, BUT YOU'RE SPEAKING --
-THAT'S NOT ENOUGH.
YOU'RE SPEAKING ON THE SAME
PRINCIPLES AND BUSINESS MODEL
THAT UBER'S ESTABLISHED ON,
OR LYFT.
O'Leary:
NO, NO. IT'S DIFFERENT.
NO, WE'RE NOT. NO, WE'RE NOT.
IT'S NOT DIFFERENT.
THERE IS A PRINTABLE FEE
THAT GOES TO THE DRIVER,
AND THERE IS A FEE
THAT'S ADDED ON TOP.
LET'S USE UBER
AS THE EXAMPLE, RIGHT?
THERE'S A REASON WHY
THEY'RE OKAY LOSING MONEY --
'CAUSE THEY'VE RAISED
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS, RIGHT?
AND THEY'RE OUT THERE
JUST TRYING TO BUILD A BRAND...
YEAH.
...TRYING TO GET PEOPLE --
WHEN THEY THINK TRANSPORTATION,
THINK UBER.
BUT THE BIGGER POINT
IS THEY CAN LIVE OFF OF CRUMBS
BASED OFF OF THE VOLUME.
YOU'RE NOT IN A POSITION
TO LIVE OFF OF CRUMBS.
AND THERE'S NOT ENOUGH CRUMBS
OUT THERE
TO MAKE THE MONEY,
REAL MONEY.
I INVESTED IN UBER
IN 2011...
I'M AWARE.
...WHEN IT WAS ONLY
IN SAN FRANCISCO,
AND UBER WAS GOING
AFTER THE ENTIRE ECOSYSTEM.
YOU KNOW, AND THE SIZE
OF THE MARKET BECAME HUMONGOUS.
AND I THINK WITH ValPark,
THAT YOU'RE GOING AFTER
A VERY NICHE MARKET.
IT'S NOT PROVEN YET.
IT'S 115 LOCATIONS
IN A TRI-STATE AREA.
THAT'S NOT A LOT
OF REAL ESTATE RIGHT NOW.
YOU KNOW, SOMEBODY CAN
COME IN YOUR OWN MARKET
AND TAKE THAT MARKET.
NO ONE CAN COME INTO MY MARKET
AND TAKE IT AWAY.
YOU'RE UNDERESTIMATING
YOUR COMPETITION.
THERE'S ANOTHER KID
IN A GARAGE
THAT WANTS TO EAT YOUR LUNCH
RIGHT NOW.
I OWN THE MAJORITY SHARE.
YOU DON'T OWN IT.
YOU THINK YOU OWN IT,
BUT NEVER UNDERESTIMATE --
I OWN THE MAJORITY SHARE, AND I
JUST DON'T SEE THAT HAPPENING.
THERE'S NO FEASIBLE SCENARIO.
I DON'T SEE MY INVESTMENT
HAPPENING. I'M OUT.
I RESPECT YOUR CONFIDENCE.
I RESPECT YOUR EFFORT.
BUT IN ORDER FOR IT TO BE WORTH
INVESTING 300K,
I'VE GOT TO BE ABLE TO SEE
SOMETHING BIG.
I TURNED DOWN UBER.
I WAS THE FIRST GUY HE WENT TO.
I TOLD HIM
IT WAS GONNA BE TOO HARD
TO GET PAST
ALL THE TAXICAB COMMISSIONS
AND THAT HE'D HAVE TO RAISE
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
SO I WAS THE BIG IDIOT
THAT SAID NO.
I'M HOPING I'M GONNA BE
JUST AS BIG AN IDIOT FOR YOU
AND THAT YOU GET JUST AS BIG.
YEAH.
BUT I DON'T SEE IT SCALING
BIG ENOUGH TO GET A RETURN.
SO FOR THOSE REASONS,
I'M OUT.
I UNDERSTAND.
I'M SORRY,
I DON'T SEE THE VISION
FOR WORLD DOMINATION
OF VALET-PARKING SYSTEMS HERE.
I JUST DON'T.
I'M OUT.
I UNDERSTAND.
YOU KNOW,
YOU ALREADY HAVE A GREAT PARTNER
WHO'S AT 46%, RIGHT?
SO THAT, FOR ME,
IS WHERE I HAVE A PROBLEM.
I LIKE HAVING A PARTNERSHIP
WHERE I FEEL LIKE
WE'RE DOING THE RIGHT THING
FOR EVERYBODY INVOLVED.
I DON'T FEEL IT'S RIGHT FOR ME
TO TAKE 30% OF YOUR COMPANY,
BUT I DON'T THINK
IT'S WORTH MY TIME
TO TAKE ANYTHING LESS,
SO I'M OUT.
I UNDERSTAND.
OKAY, ONE SHARK LEFT,
I THINK.
I SEE THIS
AS A VALUABLE PROPERTY.
I SEE THIS AS SOMETHING
THAT CAN GROW INTO CAR WASHES,
GAS STATIONS,
AND THINGS OF THAT NATURE...
-EXACTLY.
-...WHERE, YOU KNOW,
MY DAUGHTERS OR MY WIFE
OR MY MOTHER,
THEY DON'T WANT TO GET
OUT OF THE CAR,
BUT I WOULD DESPERATELY NEED
A MARK, A TROY --
WHO UNDERSTANDS SOFTWARE
AND TECHNOLOGY TO BE MY PARTNER.
SO I NEED ONE OF THESE
INDIVIDUALS IN.
AND IF ANYBODY
WANTS TO COME BACK IN,
THEN I'M OKAY WITH $300,000
FOR 20%.
BUT THEY KNOW
BETTER THAN I DO.
IT'S SCALABLE TO EVEN THE POINT
OF HOME ACCESS TO YOUR OWN HOME.
SEE IF YOU CAN GET
ANOTHER SHARK BACK IN.
YEAH, I JUST DON'T SEE IT
BEING BIG ENOUGH. I'M SORRY.
TROY?
YOU'RE NOT PARANOID ENOUGH
FOR ME.
I LOVE A PARANOID FOUNDER...
RIGHT? [ LAUGHS ]
...WHO THINKS THERE'S SOMEBODY
IN A GARAGE
WAITING TO EAT HIS LUNCH.
ALL RIGHT, WELL,
WITH THAT BEING SAID...
...I'M OUT.
THANK YOU.
-GOOD LUCK.
-GO OUT AND CRUSH IT, MAN.
Johnson:
WE'RE NOT STOPPING.
WE'VE DONE THIS
ON A SHOESTRING BUDGET.
WE'RE GETTING MORE TRACTION.
WE'RE JUST GETTING RAMPED UP.
WE'RE FAR AHEAD OF COMPETITION
THAT HAD A LOT MORE TIME
THAN WE DID.
HE'LL MAKE MONEY.
IT'LL BE A GOOD BUSINESS
FOR HIM.
BUT IT WON'T BE BIG ENOUGH
TO MAKE AN INVESTOR MONEY.
YEAH.
Narrator: NEXT INTO THE TANK IS
A TWIST ON A CLASSIC ACCESSORY.
♪♪
HI, SHARKS.
I'M ADAM TEAGUE.
AND I'M TIM PASLAY.
WE'RE THE TWO GUYS BOW TIE
COMPANY FROM TULSA, OKLAHOMA.
WE'RE SEEKING $150,000 IN
EXCHANGE FOR 10% OF OUR COMPANY.
WE HAVEN'T ALL BEEN BLESSED
WITH MR. WONDERFUL'S STRIKING
GOOD LOOKS AND ENDEARING CHARM.
SOME OF US MERE MORTALS,
WE NEED A LITTLE BIT OF HELP.
AND WE RELY ON OUR CLOTHES
TO STAND OUT.
I MEAN, GUYS,
WE'VE ALL BEEN THERE.
YOU'RE AN ELIGIBLE BACHELOR
AT A FRIEND'S WEDDING
TRYING TO GET BRIDESMAID NUMBER
THREE TO DANCE WITH YOU,
OR AT LEAST NOTICE YOU.
THE PROBLEM IS, YOU LOOK
JUST LIKE EVERYBODY ELSE --
SAME OLD SUIT AND TIE.
BUT DON'T WORRY.
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE HERE FOR.
SEPARATE YOURSELF FROM THE CROWD
WITH ONE OF OUR WOODEN BOW TIES.
WE CLEARLY CANNOT HELP YOU
WITH THE ELECTRIC SLIDE
OR THE WOBBLE,
BUT WE CAN AT LEAST
GET YOU IN THE GAME.
OUR HAND-CRAFTED ACCESSORIES
WILL MAKE A STATEMENT
ON THE DANCE FLOOR,
AT THE OFFICE CHRISTMAS PARTY,
OR ON YOUR NEXT HOT DATE.
OUR BOW TIES ARE MADE USING
OLD-SCHOOL CRAFTSMANSHIP.
WE USE A VARIETY
OF EXOTIC HARDWOODS
LIKE PERUVIAN WALNUT
OR AFRICAN ZEBRA WOOD.
BUT OUR MODERN STYLE DOESN'T
STOP WITH OUR BOW TIES.
TWO GUYS CAN SPRUCE UP
YOUR LAPEL, YOUR POCKET,
AND WE'RE EXTREMELY EXCITED
TO SHARE WITH YOU
OUR UNIQUE TAKE
ON THE TRADITIONAL FEDORA.
THESE ARE BEAUTIFULLY
CRAFTED PIECES
THAT ACTUALLY AGE WITH WEAR
AND GROW EVEN FINER OVER TIME.
SO, SHARKS, JOIN US,
AND WE'RE SURE TO MAKE MONEY.
KNOCK ON WOOD.
WE'D LOVE TO HAND OUT
SOME SAMPLES,
IF YOU GUYS ARE ALL RIGHT
WITH THAT.
PLEASE.
FINALLY, A MAN WHO GETS IT RIGHT
AND STARTS ON THIS END.
-THAT'S RIGHT.
-I WAS JUST GONNA SAY...
TROY, I GOT A BLACK FEDORA
FOR YOU.
OH, I DON'T GET A HAT?
WE FOUND OUT
YOU HAVE A REALLY BIG HEAD,
-AND NOT JUST YOUR EGO.
-[ LAUGHS ]
Greiner:
[ LAUGHS ] IT'S CUTE.
THERE YOU GO,
MR. WONDERFUL.
-THANK YOU.
-UH-HUH.
THIS IS THE SKYLINE
OF CHICAGO.
-YOU GOT IT.
-HOW CREATIVE.
-THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
-YOU GOT IT.
SO, WHERE ARE YOU CURRENTLY
SELLING THESE?
NOWHERE.
THOSE ARE JUST GETTING
READY TO LAUNCH.
WE'RE GONNA BE GOING TO A MARKET
IN ATLANTA HERE NEXT MONTH.
HOW MUCH DOES
THE BOW TIE COST?
THE CORE PRODUCT,
I ASSUME IS THE BOW TIE.
THAT'S WHAT YOU STARTED WITH,
RIGHT?
WE STARTED WITH THE BOW TIE.
THE BOW TIE RETAILS
FROM $45 TO $95.
AND WHAT'S IT COST FOR YOU
TO MAKE ONE OF THESE?
BOW TIES -- ABOUT $7.50.
AND WHERE AND HOW ARE YOU
SELLING THESE NOW?
THE MAJORITY OF OUR SALES
COME THROUGH OUR WEBSITE.
WE OBVIOUSLY LOVE THAT.
WE GET TO KEEP
THE MAJORITY OF THE MONEY.
75% OF THE SALES
COME THROUGH THE WEBSITE.
WHAT HAVE YOU DONE IN SALES
LAST YEAR?
SO, LAST YEAR,
WE DID $407,000.
WE'VE BEEN IN BUSINESS
FOR ABOUT 2 1/2 YEARS.
WE'VE DONE
JUST SHY OF $1 MILLION.
WOW.
SO, WE DO CUSTOM
REALLY WELL.
WE CAN CUSTOMIZE THE FRONT
OF THESE TO BE ANYTHING.
WE SHIP OUT CUSTOM ORDERS
NEXT DAY.
BECAUSE OF THE PROCESS
AND THE WAY WE PROCESS THINGS,
WE CAN DO
ABOUT 1,000 BOW TIES A WEEK.
YOUR LOGISTICS
ARE AMAZING, THEN.
-WE SHIP OUT --
-AND THAT'S YOUR KEY?
YOUR SATISFACTION
IS IMMEDIATE?
WE HAVE SOLD
OVER 25,000 PIECES.
WE HAVE HAD LESS THAN
30 RETURNS FOR DEFECT.
HOW ARE YOU CURRENTLY GETTING
THE WORD OUT ON THE PRODUCT?
WE'VE GOT TO GET THIS
ON TASTEMAKERS
AND STYLE INFLUENCERS.
WE'VE WORKED REALLY HARD.
I'M AN AVID NBA FAN,
SO A NATURAL OUTLET FOR ME
WAS THE NBA.
MIKE CONLEY WAS THE ONE
WHO WORE OUR BOW TIE
DURING THE NBA PLAYOFFS,
AND IT ACTUALLY --
HE GOT NOTICED
DURING THE PRESS CONFERENCE.
THEY DID A SEPARATE INTERVIEW,
THE GUYS ON "INSIDE THE NBA."
CHUCK, SHAQ, ERNIE --
WE SENT THEM SOME.
THEY WORE THEM.
THEY ALL TALKED ABOUT IT.
DID YOU SEE A SALES LIFT
AFTER THAT?
DEFINITELY.
DEFINITELY, YEAH.
ABSOLUTELY.
Carter:
I LOVE THIS STORY.
I THINK THE FEDORAS
ARE FANTASTIC.
YOU ACTUALLY SHOULD MAKE IT
A LITTLE SMALLER FOR MY HEAD.
LOOKS REALLY GOOD
ON DAYMOND.
AND I THINK THIS IS PROBABLY
MORE OF HIS EXPERTISE
THAN IT IS MINE.
AND FOR THAT REASON, I'M OUT.
OKAY.
WE'LL GET YOU A SMALLER FEDORA.
WE GOT ONE FOR YOU.
LET ME ASK YOU GUYS
A QUESTION ABOUT THIS.
AND I WANT YOUR FEEDBACK
ON IT.
YOU KNOW,
I'VE GOT A LOT OF COMPANIES
INVOLVED IN THE WEDDING
AND SPECIAL EVENTS SPACE.
ALL WE HEAR.
HONEYFUND, BOTTLE BREACHER,
WICKED GOOD CUPCAKES,
O'LEARY WINES.
I CALL IT MR. WONDERFUL'S
PLATFORM OF LOVE.
-OH, GOD.
-SO WHAT I TRY AND DO
IS INCENTIVIZE PEOPLE TO USE
ALL THE SERVICES
WHEN THEY HAVE A WEDDING
OR AN ENGAGEMENT PARTY.
-THAT'S THE IDEA.
-YEAH.
HOW MUCH DOES THAT FIT?
HOW MUCH DOES THIS
FIT INTO THAT?
SO, THE PLATFORM OF LOVE --
THE BOW TIES ARE GONNA BE
A GREAT FIT FOR THAT.
THE LAPELS AND POCKET SQUARES,
AS WELL,
BECAUSE PEOPLE WANT
THEIR WEDDING TO BE DIALED IN.
WE ACTUALLY EVEN ALLOW PEOPLE,
IF THEY WANT TO,
TO MAIL US
THEIR OWN FABRIC,
AND WE CAN MAKE THE BOW TIES
OUT OF THAT.
I LIKE THREE TIMES
IN PEOPLE'S LIVES --
WHEN THEY'RE BORN,
WHEN THEY GET MARRIED,
AND WHEN THEY DIE
BECAUSE THEY THROW CAUTION
TO THE WIND ON PRICING.
I'D LIKE TO INCLUDE THIS
ON MY PLATFORM OF LOVE,
AND I'M GONNA MAKE YOU
AN OFFER HERE.
I'M GONNA GIVE YOU $150,000,
BUT I WANT 15%.
-I THINK I ADD A LOT OF VALUE.
-YEAH.
I MEAN,
THAT'S A GREAT OFFER.
WE'D LOVE TO KIND OF CONSIDER
THAT WITH --
WOULD YOU BE INTERESTED
IN BRINGING IN A PARTNER
THAT HAS MAYBE
A DIFFERENT SKILL SET?
DEPENDS WHICH ONE.
YES, HE'S TALKING ABOUT ME,
GUYS.
I APPRECIATE THAT.
I APPRECIATE THE SHOUT-OUT.
I LIKE THIS
IN MY PORTFOLIO.
WHAT ABOUT
WITH YOUR MO'S BOWS?
YES, I DO HAVE A MENTOR.
HE'S 12 YEARS OLD.
HIS NAME IS MO'S BOWS.
HE'S A VICIOUS BUSINESSMAN.
I SEE THAT YOU GUYS
NEED LICENSING
AND PROBABLY
THE FASHION EXPERIENCE,
SO THAT MEANS
THAT I'M GONNA HAVE TO WORK
A LITTLE BIT HARDER
BECAUSE I DON'T THINK
YOU JUST WANT THE MONEY,
SO I'LL GIVE YOU 150K FOR 20%.
OKAY.
THAT'S EXCELLENT.
AND I APPRECIATE THAT.
WE'D LOVE TO, IF IT'S OKAY,
OUT OF RESPECT
FOR THE OTHER SHARKS HERE,
IF THERE'S ANYBODY ELSE...
YOU GUYS,
I'LL SIMPLIFY IT SOME --
WHILE I AM A FASHION ICON...
YOU CAN'T MAKE HATS BIG ENOUGH
TO HOLD ALL THESE BRAINS.
SO, FOR THOSE REASONS,
I'M OUT.
OKAY.
I APPRECIATE THAT.
Greiner: I WILL TELL YOU,
I THINK YOU GUYS ARE GREAT.
I THINK THAT KEVIN AND DAYMOND
ARE DEFINITELY
BETTER PARTNERS FOR YOU
AS FAR AS MARKETING AND SELLING
THE BOW TIES.
I'D BE A CUSTOMER,
BUT NOT AN INVESTOR.
I'M OUT.
AWESOME. THANK YOU.
-WE LOVE TO HEAR THAT.
-YEAH, DEFINITELY.
DAYMOND,
I HAVE A QUESTION FOR YOU.
WOULD YOU BE INTERESTED --
TROY, I KNOW YOU SAID
YOU WERE OUT --
BUT IF THERE WAS
A POTENTIAL PARTNERSHIP,
OBVIOUSLY, BECAUSE
WE FEEL LIKE YOU GUYS DO
BOTH BRING DIFFERENT ASPECTS --
OBVIOUSLY,
YOUR KIND OF NETWORK
WITH DAYMOND'S
FASHION EXPERTISE.
IS THERE A WAY
THAT WE COULD POSSIBLY FIND
A WAY TO WORK
WITH BOTH OF YOU TOGETHER?
I AM NOT ADVERSE
TO WORKING WITH TROY, YOU KNOW,
JUST DUE TO THE FACT
THAT I THINK THAT HE CAN
BRING VALUE
WITH HIS MUSIC RELATIONS.
IF HE WOULD BE INTERESTED,
THEN I THINK THAT TROY AND I --
I WOULD NEED TO GO UP TO 30%
BECAUSE I NEED TO BE ABLE TO
GET UP AND MAKE A FAIR SHARE
OF MONEY OFF OF THIS.
BUT YOU STILL
HAVE TO ASK HIM.
Narrator:
THREE SHARKS ARE OUT.
ADAM AND TIM HAVE TWO OFFERS
ON THE TABLE
FROM DAYMOND AND KEVIN
FOR THEIR WOODEN-ACCESSORY
COMPANY, TWO GUYS BOW TIES.
BUT THEY'VE ASKED DAYMOND
IF HE'D BE INTERESTED
IN PARTNERING WITH TROY
ON A DEAL.
I THINK THAT TROY AND I --
I WOULD NEED TO GO UP TO 30%
'CAUSE I NEED TO BE ABLE
TO GET UP AND MAKE A FAIR SHARE
OF MONEY OFF OF THIS.
BUT YOU STILL
HAVE TO ASK HIM.
YOU KNOW WHAT, DAYMOND...
IF THESE GUYS ARE WILLING
TO GO UP TO 30% FOR THAT PRICE,
I THINK WE'D MAKE GOOD PARTNERS
ON THIS.
ALL RIGHT.
WHAT DO YOU GUYS THINK?
SO, 30%'S A LITTLE HIGHER
THAN WE ARE WANTING TO GO.
I'M TAKING OFF THE HAT, GUYS.
SO OUR COUNTER WOULD
PROBABLY BE 20%
WITH A 5% ROYALTY UNTIL YOU GOT
YOUR INVESTMENT BACK.
WHY DON'T YOU GIVE US
A 10% ROYALTY ON THAT?
I MEAN, THE BUMP OF, OBVIOUSLY,
WHAT WE DO
AND BRING THE VALUE TO IT
WILL INCREASE
YOUR NUMBERS GREATLY.
O'Leary:
I'LL MAKE IT INTERESTING
JUST TO MAKE IT COMPETITIVE.
I'LL DROP MY EQUITY ASK
DOWN TO 10%, NOT 15%.
I'LL DROP THE ROYALTY DOWN
TO 7.5%,
AND I'LL PUT IT
ON THE PLATFORM OF LOVE,
WHICH I THINK IS INVALUABLE
FOR YOU GUYS.
OKAY.
I'M OUT.
OOH.
THAT'S NASTY, GUYS.
WOW.
BA-BAM, TROY.
HE'S A DISCIPLINED MAN.
I CAN SEE THAT.
WELL, NOW THAT I ALREADY
HAVE A THIRST
FOR THE BLOOD OF 10% ROYALTY,
I'M GONNA KEEP IT AT THAT.
150K, 20% EQUITY, 10% ROYALTY
UNTIL I RECEIVE THE 150K BACK.
WOW.
THAT'S EXPENSIVE.
THAT IS EXPENSIVE.
WELL, I'D LOVE TO COUNTER,
IF I COULD.
RIGHT NOW YOU'RE AT 20%
FOR $150,000 WITH A 10% ROYALTY.
-UNTIL THE MONEY IS RECOUPED.
-UNTIL YOU GET YOUR MONEY BACK.
WOULD YOU BE WILLING TO DO
17.5% WITH A 10% ROYALTY
UNTIL YOU GET
YOUR MONEY BACK?
YOU THINK I'M GONNA ARGUE
OVER 2.5%?
I WOULD HOPE NOT.
ALL RIGHT,
I'M GONNA GIVE YOU TWO GUESSES,
BUT YOU'RE ONLY GONNA NEED ONE,
WHAT I'M GONNA SAY.
DEAL.
DONE. LET'S GO.
ALL RIGHT.
APPRECIATE YOU, MAN.
THANK YOU.
Greiner: GOOD DEAL.
AND I'M GONNA MODEL THIS
FOR FREE, MAN.
-ABSOLUTELY. WE APPRECIATE IT.
-LOOKING SHARP IN IT.
TROY, I APPRECIATE YOU LETTING
ME GET A LITTLE BIT MORE.
Teague: IT'S EMOTIONAL
TO TAKE SOMETHING
THAT YOU'VE WORKED TO BUILD
SO HARD
AND THEN TO GIVE
A PIECE OF THAT AWAY,
BUT WE FEEL LIKE WITH DAYMOND,
WE GET SO MUCH IN RETURN.
HIS EXPERTISE AND EXPERIENCE
IN THIS INDUSTRY
IS GONNA BE AMAZING FOR US.
I'M DON HEJNY.
THIS IS MY WIFE, LYDIA.
AND WE LIVE
IN NASHVILLE, TENNESSEE,
WITH OUR THREE BEAUTIFUL KIDS,
DIA, ASAIAH, AND LUCY.
I WEAR GLASSES
EVERY SINGLE DAY.
AND SOMETHING HAS ALWAYS
REALLY BOTHERED ME.
ONE DAY,
THE LIGHT BULB WENT OFF,
AND I CAME UP
WITH A REALLY SIMPLE FIX
TO A VERY ANNOYING PROBLEM.
Lydia: AS FIRST-TIME
ENTREPRENEURS,
WE'RE LEARNING AS WE GO,
AND WE DEFINITELY HAD
SOME SETBACKS.
WE'VE TRIED USING
A MANUFACTURER,
BUT WHEN OUR PRODUCT
CAME OFF THE LINE,
THEY WERE ALL DEFECTIVE.
IT WAS A NIGHTMARE.
IT PUT US
A MONTH BEHIND SCHEDULE,
AND WE LOST
A TON OF INVENTORY.
WE'RE BACK TO MAKING OUR PRODUCT
BY HAND AT HOME.
WE GOT
A LOT OF WORK TO DO.
-YES.
-[ LAUGHS ]
WE NEED AN INVESTMENT
FROM THE SHARKS
TO HELP US SCALE
OUR BUSINESS,
BUT WE ALSO NEED
THE EXPERTISE
OF SOMEONE WHO'S BEEN DOWN
THIS ROAD BEFORE.
WE CAN'T AFFORD TO MAKE
ANY MORE MISTAKES.
-I WANT TO DO THE LAST ONE.
-OKAY.
Don: THIS BUSINESS MEANS
DOING SOMETHING THAT I LOVE
WHILE BEING WITH THE PEOPLE
THAT I LOVE.
AND ON TOP OF THAT,
WE GET TO HELP PEOPLE
ALL OVER THE WORLD
MAKE THEIR LIVES
JUST A LITTLE
LESS FRUSTRATING.
IT DOESN'T GET
ANY BETTER THAN THAT.
♪♪
-HEY, SHARKS. I'M DON.
-I'M LYDIA.
-DIA.
-AND I'M ASAIAH.
WE'RE THE HEJNYS,
AND OUR COMPANY IS NERDWAX.
WE'RE HERE TODAY SEEKING
AN $80,000 INVESTMENT
FOR 20% EQUITY STAKE
IN OUR COMPANY.
WE LOVE WEARING GLASSES.
GLASSES AND SUNGLASSES
DON'T JUST HELP US SEE BETTER.
THEY'RE ALSO A FABULOUS WAY
TO SHOW OFF YOUR UNIQUE STYLE.
BUT THOSE OF US
WHO LOVE WEARING GLASSES
ALSO KNOW IT'S HARD TO KEEP
THE GLASSES WE LOVE ON OUR FACE.
YEAH, THEY'RE ALWAYS
SLIDING DOWN OUR NOSE,
AND WE'RE CONSTANTLY
ADJUSTING THEM.
THAT'S WHY MY DAD
INVENTED...
NERDWAX!
Don: NERDWAX
IS A BEESWAX-BASED BLEND
OF ALL-NATURAL AND CERTIFIED
ORGANIC INGREDIENTS
SPECIALLY FORMULATED
TO KEEP YOUR GLASSES IN PLACE.
SO, HOW DOES IT WORK?
-IT'S SUPER SIMPLE.
FIRST, YOU'RE GONNA WIPE OFF
YOUR NOSE PADS
OR BRIDGE OF YOUR GLASSES.
AND THEN YOU ROLL
YOUR NERDWAX OUT A GOOD BIT.
AND YOU APPLY IT DIRECTLY
TO THE BRIDGE
OR NOSE PADS
OF YOUR FAVORITE GLASSES.
NERDWAX WILL SIMPLY WEAR OFF
NATURALLY OVER TIME.
AND THAT'S IT.
WE'VE ALREADY CHANGED
THE WAY
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
WEAR THEIR GLASSES,
BUT WE NEED YOUR HELP
TO MAKE IT MILLIONS.
SO, WHO WANTS TO WAX ON
WITH US?
AND STOP THE SLIDE?
[ CHUCKLES ]
SO, LYDIA, DIA, AND ASAIAH
ARE GONNA PASS OUT SOME SAMPLES.
THANK YOU.
LIKE YOUR GLASSES.
LET'S GIVE THESE
TO DAYMOND.
GOOD JOB, BIG GUY.
THANKS.
Don:
TROY, AS YOU'RE PUTTING IT ON,
MAKE SURE YOU ROLL
THE TUBE OUT A GOOD BIT
AND KIND OF USE
THE EDGE OF IT.
THE GREAT THING ABOUT IT
IS THAT YOU CAN CONTROL
THE AMOUNT
THAT YOU PUT ON IT.
SO YOU CAN TRY JUST A LITTLE BIT
AND SEE HOW IT WORKS,
AND YOU CAN GIVE IT
A LITTLE BIT MORE
AND SEE WHAT YOU LIKE
ABOUT IT.
HEY, YOU GUYS DID AWESOME.
-WHOO-HOO!
-GOOD JOB, GUYS.
-GOOD JOB.
-GIVE ME FIVE.
-I'LL SEE YOU LATER.
-BYE, DAD.
-BYE.
HOW DID YOU COME UP
WITH THIS IDEA?
SO, FIVE YEARS AGO,
I WAS A TOURING AUDIO ENGINEER.
I WORKED
IN THE MUSIC INDUSTRY,
AND I WORKED OUTSIDE
IN THE SUMMER.
WE DID A TON OF OUTDOOR CONCERTS
AND FESTIVALS.
AND I WOULD GET SUPER SWEATY.
MY GLASSES
WERE ALWAYS SLIDING DOWN.
AND I LOOKED ALL OVER
THE INTERNET FOR A SOLUTION.
EVERYTHING I FOUND
WAS EITHER UNCOMFORTABLE,
IT DIDN'T WORK,
OR IT WAS JUST STRAIGHT-UP UGLY.
SO, IT'S MADE OUT OF BEESWAX?
YEAH, SO, IT'S A BEESWAX BASE,
BUT IT'S A SPECIAL FORMULATION.
SO IT'S NOT ChapStick, ALTHOUGH
WE HAVE THE LIP-BALM CONTAINER.
IT'S A COMPLETELY NEW
FORMULATION.
BUT ALL THE INGREDIENTS
THAT ARE IN THERE
ARE ALL-NATURAL,
COMPLETELY ORGANIC,
AND THEY'RE COSMETIC-GRADE
INGREDIENTS.
SO YOU DON'T HAVE TO WORRY
ABOUT YOUR FACE
BREAKING OUT
OR ANYTHING LIKE THAT.
WHERE DOES IT SIT AT
ON THE SHELF?
WE SELL ONLINE -- $10.
AND THEN WE ALSO HAVE
30 WHOLESALERS.
AND WHAT'S THE COST OF GOODS?
-IT'S 35 CENTS PER TUBE.
-WHOA.
-AT LEAST YOU GOT GOOD MARGINS.
-YOU HAVE A NICE MARGIN.
-WE HAVE GREAT MARGINS, YEAH.
-AND HOW MUCH HAVE YOU SOLD?
SO, WE HAVE SOLD,
TO DATE...
$136,000.
Cuban: WELL, GOOD.
AND OFF OF THE $136,000,
WE HAVE $65,000 IN PROFIT.
-WOW.
-OVER WHAT PERIOD OF TIME?
THAT'S THE EXCITING PART --
WE JUST STARTED.
APRIL OF LAST YEAR,
WE BEGAN SELLING
DIRECT TO THE CONSUMER
ONLINE VIA OUR WEBSITE.
AND WHEN WE STARTED DOING THAT,
WE GOT A TON OF PUSH ONLINE.
WE WERE FEATURED IN MASHABLE,
UNCRATE, BUZZFEED, AOL.
-YAHOO!, DAILY MAIL.
-DAILY MAIL.
YOU'RE GETTING --
I CALL IT P.R. VIAGRA, RIGHT?
YOU'RE GETTING ALL THESE --
YEAH, WE HAVE TONS OF SPIKES
AND VALLEYS.
ALL YOUR SPIKES THAT RELATE
TO WHEN YOU GET MEDIA, RIGHT?
HOW ARE YOU GONNA DO
WITHOUT MEDIA?
WHAT ARE YOU GONNA DO
WHEN THE MEDIA DIES?
SO, WE'RE GONNA CONTINUE
DOING WHAT WORKS.
RIGHT NOW WE'RE MEASURING
EVERYTHING THAT WE DO ON SOCIAL.
SO WE'RE GOING OUT THERE,
AND WE'RE JUST STIRRING UP
THE CONVERSATION.
WE'RE GONNA KEEP DOING
WHAT WE DO BETTER,
AND THEN WE'RE GOING
TO IMPROVE ON IT.
HOW MANY RE-ORDERS
ARE YOU GETTING
FROM THE PEOPLE
THAT HAVE ORDERED IN THE PAST?
WE'VE ESTIMATED
THAT YOU'LL GET
SIX TO EIGHT MONTHS
OUT OF A SINGLE TUBE.
SO JUST NOW,
WE'RE STARTING TO SEE
PEOPLE COME BACK
AND RE-ORDER.
THAT'S A LOT OF TIME.
Greiner: YEAH, 'CAUSE IT DOESN'T
RUN OUT THAT FAST.
-YOU JUST USE A LITTLE BIT.
-IT DOESN'T RUN OUT THAT FAST.
YOU JUST USE A LITTLE BIT.
EIGHT MONTHS IS AN ETERNITY
BEFORE THE RE-PURCHASE.
I AGREE.
I WOULD MAKE THE TUBE
SMALLER, THINNER,
SO IT DOESN'T LOOK LIKE
IT'S LIP BALM.
AND I WOULD REDUCE THE AMOUNT
BY 60%.
SO I'M BASICALLY ONLY SELLING
90 DAYS' WORTH OF SUPPLY.
I'D DROP THE PRICE
TO $3.99, TO $4.99.
AND THEN I'D FIND OUT
THE SWEET SPOT.
NOBODY'S GONNA SPEND $10
ON NERDWAX.
IT'S TOO MUCH MONEY.
THAT'S THE WORST THING
THEY COULD EVER DO.
AND, LOOK,
I DON'T CARE WHAT MARK THINKS.
-IT WOULD BE HORRIBLE.
-I'M ALWAYS RIGHT.
I KNOW WHAT I'M DOING HERE.
THIS IS WHY IT'S NOT WORKING.
-WE'RE PROFITABLE TODAY.
-EXACTLY!
I THINK YOU'D SELL SO MUCH MORE
IF YOUR PRICE WAS WAY LOWER.
YEAH, THAT WOULD BE
A HUGE MISTAKE.
NO, WELL --
TO ME, YOU NEED TO GET OUT
THERE, GET WIDESPREAD...
-NO.
-...AND MOVE VOLUME.
NO.
I DON'T SEE THIS --
WELL, I KNOW YOU DON'T AGREE
WITH ME, MARK,
BUT I'VE SOLD A LOT OF PRODUCT
OVER THE YEARS.
YEAH.
I ALWAYS THINK IT'S SMART
TO CRAWL, THEN WALK, THEN RUN.
AND I FEEL LIKE
I'M LYING TO MYSELF IF I SAID,
"I THINK I'LL MAKE BACK
MY MONEY."
SO I'M OUT.
OKAY, SO, IT'S TOO EARLY
FOR ME,
AND I DON'T THINK YOU NEED
THE INVESTMENT. I'M OUT.
I'M SORRY TO HEAR THAT,
DAYMOND.
WE ARE HERE FOR AN INVESTMENT
FOR A VERY SPECIFIC REASON.
WHAT ARE YOU GONNA USE
THE MONEY FOR?
WE NEED WORKING CAPITAL
TO GROW THIS THING AND SCALE.
WHY GIVE AWAY
PART OF YOUR COMPANY RIGHT NOW
-FOR THAT AMOUNT OF MONEY?
-YEAH, I MEAN, LOOK --
THIS IS THE ONLY TIME
YOU NEED TO VALUE SWEAT,
WHICH IS SWEAT EQUITY.
OH, AND THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE PUTTING IN.
IN A YEAR FROM NOW, THAT 20%
WILL BE WORTH SO MUCH MORE.
SO WE'RE PUTTING IT IN, AND
WE'RE GONNA CONTINUE TO DO THAT.
WE'RE NOT AFRAID OF WORK.
WE'VE PROVEN THAT.
WE'RE GONNA DO IT.
WE'RE SCRAPPY.
WE'RE GONNA HUSTLE.
GUYS, I BEG YOU NOT TO TAKE IN
ANY MONEY RIGHT NOW.
I KNOW THAT WE TOOK A RISK
IN BEING HERE EARLY,
BUT I ALSO KNOW
THAT EVERYTHING THAT HAS COME,
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO GET UP THERE
AND CRUSH IT.
SO I KNOW
THAT WE CAN DO THIS.
AND I KNOW THAT GOING
BEYOND THIS,
WE'RE GONNA
JUST FIGURE IT OUT.
HERE'S THE ONLY WAY I WOULD
DO THIS DEAL, ALL RIGHT?
I'M A MARKETING GENIUS, OKAY?
I KNOW THAT ABOUT MYSELF.
THE WAY THIS THING WORKS,
FOR ME,
IS YOU'RE SO EARLY,
YET YOU DO NEED CAPITAL.
THIS IS VENTURE DEBT.
IT'S THE ONLY WAY I WOULD DO IT.
HERE COMES
HIS BLOOD-SUCKING OFFER.
SILENCE.
I WANT SILENCE
SO THEY CAN HEAR THE OFFER.
I THINK YOU'RE A PRODUCT,
NOT A COMPANY.
SO I'M WILLING TO GIVE YOU
$80,000,
BUT I WANT 10% OF SALES
UNTIL I GET $240,000 BACK.
AND BECAUSE I'M MR. WONDERFUL,
YOU'RE GONNA GIVE ME
3% OF THE COMPANY.
LISTEN, LET'S DEAL
WITH THE TRUTH, OKAY?
IT'S A PRODUCT.
IT'S NOT A COMPANY.
GUYS, I THINK
TRYING TO GO HIGH-VOLUME --
BIGGEST MISTAKE
YOU CAN MAKE.
GO FROM $100,000 IN SALES
TO $500,000
TO $1 MILLION IN SALES,
AND, OH, YOU'LL BE MAKING
$900,000 A YEAR.
-IT COULD BE A WHOLE LOT WORSE.
-YEAH.
SOMETIMES WHEN YOU TRY TO GET
TOO BIG TOO FAST,
THINGS GO IN DIRECTIONS
YOU DON'T EXPECT.
RIGHT NOW YOU CAN CONTROL
YOUR OWN DESTINY.
THIS IS A GREAT
SMALL BUSINESS,
BUT IT'S NOT REALLY
AN INVESTABLE BUSINESS.
AND SO FOR THOSE REASONS,
I'M OUT.
I'M SORRY TO HEAR THAT,
MARK.
I REALLY WANTED TO WORK
WITH YOU.
ALL RIGHT.
TROY'S STILL IN.
WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
LET'S HAVE SOME FUN.
I AGREE, YOU GUYS ARE EARLY,
BUT I LIKE TO BE THERE EARLY.
SO, I WAS ONE OF THE EARLY
INVESTORS IN WARBY PARKER --
THE FASTEST-GROWING GLASSES
COMPANY IN THE WORLD RIGHT NOW.
ALREADY WORTH OVER $1 BILLION.
SO WHAT I WOULD OFFER --
I'D SAY I'LL GIVE YOU
THE $80,000 AS A LOAN
UNTIL I RECOUP $120,000,
PLUS YOU GIVE ME
10% OF THE COMPANY.
KEVIN JR. IN THE HOUSE!
HE HAS LEARNED WISELY.
HE'S GONNA GIVE YOU
THE $80,000,
BUT THE COST BACK
IS MUCH LESS THAN ME.
HE WANTS $120,000 BACK,
BUT THE EQUITY PURCHASE AMOUNT
THAT HE WANTS IS MUCH HIGHER.
IT'S 10%.
I'M PUTTING MORE OF MY RISK
IN THE COMPANY'S ABILITY
TO PAY ME BACK.
I'M SAYING
I'LL GIVE YOU $80,000.
I WANT $240,000 BACK.
BUT YOU DON'T JUST WANT MONEY.
YOU WANT A PARTNER.
YEAH, WE DO.
YOU NEED SOMEBODY
TO HELP YOU BUILD THIS BRAND.
YEAH, 'CAUSE ALL YOU GOT TO DO
IS SELL 250K WORTH OF PRODUCT,
AND YOU GET
THE SAME AMOUNT OF CASH.
Don: AND WE'RE CONFIDENT
THAT WE'RE GONNA GET THERE.
AND I THINK WE'RE GONNA
GET THERE NEXT YEAR.
THE PROBLEM THAT I HAVE
WITH THE OFFERS RIGHT NOW
IS WE DON'T DO DEBT.
WE HAVE NO DEBT
ON THE COMPANY TODAY.
WE WANT TO KEEP IT
THAT WAY.
YOU'RE NOT A COMPANY.
SEE, THEN, HE DOESN'T BELIEVE,
RIGHT?
LOOK, IF YOU
BELIEVE IN THE COMPANY --
WELL, THEN,
YOU DO IT, MARK.
NO, LOOK,
IF YOU BELIEVE IN THE COMPANY,
THEN YOU WANT THEM
TO RE-INVEST IN THE COMPANY.
THEN YOU SHOULD
WRITE A CHECK.
I LOVE A GUY
THAT'S WILLING TO GIVE ADVICE,
BUT HE WON'T WRITE A CHECK,
ALL RIGHT?
I'M WILLING TO WRITE A CHECK.
DO YOU WANT TO DO A DEAL OR NOT?
YEAH. SO, AT THIS TIME,
I THINK THAT WE --
I THINK THAT WE RESPECTFULLY
HAVE TO DECLINE THOSE OFFERS.
YES!
YOU TOOK MY ADVICE!
OKAY.
CONGRATULATIONS, GUYS.
NERDWAX GUYS,
YOU'RE DEAD TO ME.
THANKS FOR YOUR TIME.
CONGRATULATIONS
ON YOUR COMPANY, GUYS.
Don: SO, WE KNOW WE WALKED AWAY
FROM SOME MONEY TODAY,
BUT LIKE MARK SAID,
WE HAVE REALLY HIGH MARGINS.
IF WE GO OUT
AND WE CONTINUE TO DO
WHAT WE'RE DOING,
WE'RE GONNA GET THERE.
IT MAY JUST TAKE US
A LITTLE BIT LONGER,
BUT WE'RE GONNA MAKE
THIS THING HAPPEN.